اهميه تكثيف الجهود للتوصل الى تسويه
شامله وعادله للقضيه الفلسطينيه ضروره
التهدئه وتغيب لغه الحوار والحفاظ على
المؤسسات الوطنيه في السودان
اهميه مواصله وتكثيف الجهود العربيه
الراميه الى مساعده سوريا لتجاوز ازمتها
دعم الجهود الامميه والاقليميه للتوصل الى
حل سياسي شامل للازمه اليمنيه التضامن
التام مع لبنان والدعوه الى انتخاب رئيس
جمهوريه يرضي طموحات اللبنانيين التشديد
على وقف التدخلات الخارجيه في الشؤون
الداخليه للدول العربيه
التنميه المستدامه والامر والاستقرار
والعيش في سلام حق اصيل للمواطن العربي
اهميه استثمار الموارد والفرص والامكانات
لتحقيق نهضه عربيه صناعيه وزراعيه شامله
الالتزام بقيم الحوار والتسامح وعدم
التدخل في شؤون الاخرين تحت اي ذريعه
المحافظه على الثقافه والهويه العربيه
الاصيله وابراز الموروث الحضاري والفكري
الاشاده بحرص السعوديه على توفير الظروف
الملائمه لتحقيق الاستقرار والنمو
الاقتصادي
مبادره انشاء حاويه فكريه للبحوث
والدراسات في الاستدامه والتنميه
الاقتصاديه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات